[Applaudissements]
pour s'asseoir dans un baquet de
voitures de course il vaut mieux avoir
la foi en dieu ou au moins dans le
pilote
et ça tombe bien david mackerras les
deux donc forcément il ne crée rien les
babas
[Musique]
enfin
c'est un vrai métier c'est vrai vrai
professionnalisme et ça donne beaucoup
de leçons
beaucoup de leçons voilà déjà son dieu
était dans la voiture ah oui mais
j'espère qu'il est souvent avec ceux qui
pilotent et puis tous ceux qui prennent
leurs hôtes le matin pour aller au
travail
l'aller retour pour le paradis de la
vitesse a semble-t-il des vertus
euphorisantes
à en juger par les sourires affichés
s'accéler à saint fraigne ça vire
ça tient la route c'est si magique et
avec six mois joseph au volant je suis
entre de bonnes mains j'ai un champion
du monde devant moi donc il n'y a pas
d'inquiétude ya pas de doute et je suis
quelqu'un j'adore la vitesse on voit
bien tout ce qui est fait tout ce qui
est mis en place
en tout cas s'agissant de de la sécurité
on voit avec des pilotes comme simon la
maîtrise l'expertisé non vraiment il
faut qu'on puisse continuer à encourager
le sport mécanique pour que tous ceux
qui y sont un peu fan de vitesse et
cetera
ben puissent le faire en toute sécurité
en tout en tout professionnalisme
parce que il ya du professionnalisme
derrière il faut dire qu'au delà du
talent des pilotes de rallye
la véritable star de cette compétition
c'est la catégorie r5 près de 300
chevaux 4 roues motrices 50 mètres
linéaires d'arceau de protection un
engin affûté pour les chronos de la
pression des pneus aux carburants
spécifique à 4 euros le litre en passant
par ce volant digne d'un jeu vidéo
pour être plus efficace on a tout sur le
volant et tout portée de main donc là il
ya les essuie là sa vie à les
clignotants il est le démarrage de
klaxons et ensuite ce sont des
procédures pour dédé stratégie de départ
pour des pour des cartographies
différentes en fonction du temps si
c'est sec nouilles et où c'est sûr si on
roule sur la terre donc c'est vraiment
très concentré
l'antichambre du championnat du monde
accessible neuf aux environs de 200
mille euros
à voir dès demain soir sur le fond de
mer de fort de france
[Musique]